et son anniversaire à jean luc lemoine
les questions en 4/3
bonjour jean luc merci d'être là mais ça
fait plaisir je ne vous avais pas vu
mais je suis assez discret oui et c'est
mon anniversaire je vais faire des
cadeaux à tout le monde r alors mieux
aller bref c'est bon ça va et les
bonhommes
oui la bonne âme bonjour je m'appelle
marvin comme vous passez tout votre
temps à la télé j'imagine que vous ne
devez pas avoir de vie privée donc je
voulais savoir est ce que pour vous
détendre des invités ont la gentillesse
de coucher avec vous justement c'est une
très bonne question marine mais là sinon
les invités sont assez égoïste et refuse
de coucher avec nous alors qu'il
suffirait qu'un seul donne l'exemple
ce ne sera pas ce soir ce que personne
ne réponde aux avances malgré des
signaux discret envoyée par jean michel
comme ici sur l'entrée de la chanteuse
ce talent
qu'elle dise ce qu'elle vit cela well as
raison il faut dire qu'il est à cran
jean mimi à regarder le quand on pose
une question simple à valérie benaïm
alors on en est où qu'est ce qu'elle a
fait hier soir mercredi soir avec
pactole qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
cinoche non mais non mais tranquille à
la maison
vous allez enfin de la partie qui nous
embêtait patoche l'impression que c'est
la fin des haricots des tours à 6,6
alors vous aurez remarqué son geste
son geste un jean-luc pour dire ça il
fait ça donc voilà apparemment non mais
c'est pas non mais c'est là c'est une
voiture au labeur mais c'est pas mal ça
donne envie en tout cas merci le roi du
leem on va pas vous mentir à force de
rester enfermé certains d'entre nous
commencent à craquer là par exemple
elodie gossuin révélé qu'elle avait un
bête et oui sur une partie intime de son
corps c'est bertrand c'est votre mecha
mon mari quoi c'est beau la feta to be
ce à dire que non mais ça veut dire que
système u si ça se termine avec lui elle
est obligée de sortir avec un benoît
boris
les obliger à boulanger isabelle
contrairement aux idées reçues beat
n'est pas un prénom chaque niche allons
d'ailleurs c'est beau c'est bon c'est ça
à force de discuter que jean-michel
pasqua dit morini bosc
si je crois qu'ils discuteront avec
jean-michel parce que les deux vous avez
pas idée c'est cul et chemise ils ont
plus aucun secret l'un pour l'autre
garder
ça m'ennuie je commence vraiment avec
chaumont
oui encore
on les voit souvent chez la copine
comment ces primaires sont moins élevés
du melody vous êtes comme moi mais je
suis désespéré choqué non mais
franchement honte sur toi quand même non
c'était conseils malins du jour et ma
mère qui regardent l'émission à mort et
ce n'est pas du passé c'est bien mais ça
reste courtois exactement respect de je
suis désolé on dit que je m'acharne sur
jean-michel mais je vous rappelle que
c'est quand même le mec qui a osé
raconter la technique du kinder surprise
à l'antenne je sais pas si vous vous
souvenez ça ça c'était pas un off
je trouvais une nouvelle technique de
drague qui marche qui marche pas mal non
série alors quelle est cette technique
de la non écoute chez les jeunes je
sélectionne une des filles dans la boîte
de nuit je la ramène dans la voie là et
je lui dis que j'ai un cadeau poil hélas
pas juste un kinder surprise parce que
les filles aiment bien les kinder bah
oui enfin j'imagine
elle prend le kinder louvre et puis en
fait je me suis débrouillé avant pour
retirer la surprise on est là où
absolument rien dans l'oeuf
évidemment elle dit ben où elle est ma
surprise judy balle est dans mon slip eu
de la chance
c'est désormais pour l'avenir de nawel
utile de cadeaux à 9
non mais normalement après ce genre de
révélations tu te caches tu quittes la
france et oui l'état vis à l'étranger
et ben non jean michel lui regardez ils
étaient contents portée
vous êtes ce que vous allez voir ce qui
n'était là pour le sanctionner série qui
se donne un mal de chien pour nous
remettre dans le droit la wii bah oui
vous inculquer des valeurs ses valeurs
vous pensez qu'il faut dit il faut dire
toujours la vérité ou pas au semestre
non surtout pas jamais de la vie ah
ouais bah non c'est une vérité oui cyril
toujours là c'est rythmé voudrais qu'on
fasse pareil évident cb je vais essayer
d'ailleurs j'ai trouvé un extrait
bizarre mais ça c'est juste avant que
jean-michel nous raconte une histoire de
kinder
face à la sala si un commentaire là
dessus non mais je ne vois pas écouté
non pas la vérité mais non je n'ai rien
de toute façon la vérité c'est la vérité
je vous dire la vérité je racontais il
aura contre lui à regarder
jean michel et tu peux préciser sa
pensée sa mairie dans mad avions relaté
dans la loge tous les deux jeudi cédant
j'ai une histoire fabuleuse autre à côté
c'est vrai pas sur michel je racontais
l'histoire du kinder et là il m'a dit
j'ai dit mais je pense que tu seras plus
apte alors raconté à l'antenne et donc
il a regoûté et vous avez été génial et
donc ça reste est formidable c'est que
vous l'avez demandé ça et après vous
l'avez sorti
oui parce que c'est pour le remercier en
fred a beaucoup c'est boonen c'est parce
que je savais qu'il avait il
il avait été trop loin il a rajouté elle
était déjà montée ça c'était drôle mais
j'ai pas aimé mais je fais d'accord mais
je suis déçu quand même c'est pas gilles
verdez qui aurait tenu des propos à jean
louis c'est un vrai romantique même si
parfois on a du mal à suivre ce
raisonnement
moi ma spécialité c'est la vaisselle
ouais et ça se voit y'a pas de lave
vaisselle que j'ai toujours pensé que
les lave vaisselle
c'était un problème pour le couple la
vaisselle ses consoles de couple et à de
l'eau qui coule on se bat avec toi voilà
alors la suite des violents mais c'est
pas le début je pense que gilles se
drogue mais mes thierry et jean michel
ont une autre explication là dessus la
maîtrise
évidez ou alors ils aiment voir sa femme
en six mois alors ses diverses
la viande a baissé en mai
m
dégueulasse et les jours c ommission
quand même vous vivez comment quand vous
voyez ça vous quand on voit les envoyer
les images la laisse parfois on a honte
et puis parfois on se bat et puis
parfois on se dit pourquoi on se fait
toujours piégés comme sa smart plus
souvent qu'on a on se marre que les gens
ont honte pour vous vous avez des pistes
pour vous pour dix générations vous ai
compris gilles verdez fait la vaisselle
en guêpière il ya des choses qu'on
n'aurait pas savoir mais plus seulement
la passion et vous savez peut-être c'est
la musique
c'est un mec simple tout ce qu'il veut
c'est du bon son les mesquineries dire
du mal des gens comme vous le faites pas
c'est pas pour lui faut les regarder
tu t'énerves il le pensait pas un nom
mais comme ça te file c'est la face à
lui pas encore remonté après c'est ça
donc vous ne regrettez pas là c'est au
genou donc on va continuer il a reparlé
de ton travail juste après en plus
arrondies jay sa chance tout quand même
à boire tout là je sais pas si tu aime
beaucoup un don vous le savez deux dj en
alternance tous et moux il a aussi son
avis sur books là c'était encore te fare
aux platines
les mousses du trio si tu vois que blue
car dans ces mêmes la daube
non ah oui tu la vois pas ici donc c'est
plus dans la vibe
merci il vient de comprendre en fait
bien comprendre il exprime par la
musique est là il est au top de son
énervement je l'aï les îles et colère
l'a vraiment voilà je crois j'ai bien
foutu la merde vous remarquez au passage
que pour défendre te fin on peut compter
sur thierry mauron pour ne rien faire
bad est d'ailleurs en parlant de thierry
la semaine dernière des dernières 4/3 ce
que je vais réussir à dire je vais fait
découvrir sa science de la vanne les
depuis beaucoup de gens m'ont écrit en
me disant bon c'est pas tout d'avoir des
bonnes vannes
il faut savoir les places et comment
faire donc tout de suite une leçon de
notre spécialiste
nous recevions le nageur amaury leveaux
oui et thierry lévy évidemment préparé
une blagounette leveaux la vache
alors je vous laisse les extraits dans
son intégralité pour que vous admiriez
la tristesse
un beau champion olympique champion du
monde et vient nous voir comme ça pour
nous faire imposer second tour après sa
rentrée ce matin
amaury tiens je vais plus grand nageur
de ces dix dernières années il vient
d'annoncer qu'il prenait sa voix à la
vache un sens du timing
ah oui vraiment clients suivants jean
michel et jordan et c'est à dire sur
valérie et que je vais me tourner le dos
tout le temps est maintenant très jolie
jeune fille à cause de ses bottes pas
bien c'est vrai que vous êtes très belle
valérie sachets non mais ces droits la
lourdeur au michigan il ya deux semaines
nous avions décidé enfin surtout syrie
d'ailleurs de faire un show nyha i télé
ah oui alors je veux revenir un petit
peu dans le temps la dernière fois que
cyril avait envahi les studios de la
chaîne info
c'était pour vendre des beignets y lopez
et sablé le billon puisqu'on a par
contre oubliez c'est qu'ils étaient
accompagnés de jean michel qui n'avaient
pas de micro donc à l'époque il avait
été très créatifs pour exister
regardez le en slip
voulez vous dire ma touche pas à mon
poste on s'est fait d'un morceau choisi
frédéric au basket avec nous frédéric là
parce qu'on retrouve dans rendez vous en
terre inconnue jusqu'à le 24 septembre
qui jouait dans 3 0 dans un région est
un footballeur ça met mobilières mais là
on parle des mystères de la seconde
guerre mondiale et ce train on l'a vu la
cuisse fait du gard débarquera que
jean-michel été créatifs du beignet
quelqu'un qui dit retour a été lady
retour de jean michel le troll sauf que
là la sécurité n'a pas laissé entrer
cyril et bah c'est pas grave pour jean
michel aulas donc c'était les funambules
du jour allez on va donc continuer à
cette émission voilà c'est n'importe
quoi c'est quand même se méfier de
s'incruster dans l'émission dans
laquelle ils travaillent
c'est une maladie peut pas s'empêcher
regarder encore c'est vraiment un fiasco
cette séquence
j'en ai marre sont décollées vous me
fatiguez voilà donc au nac
cet incident la prison et pour finir les
un petit plaisir à aragon un bon vous le
savez que celui qui perd au toît du
poste et déguisés mai est le jour on a
reçu un marc olivier fogiel est basse et
gilles qui étaient déguisées
il a très bien vécu il n'y a pas de
dialogue bien que sa tête ça a fait mon
bonheur
croyant et c'est pour ça que je veux
gagner toutes les émissions parce que
tout le monde tout le monde en prend
plein la gueule même le nommer plus
grand de tous
le port d'al arich
bonjour je m'appelle à nyeri corps je
suis très choqué j'ai croisé jean michel
maire dans la rue et pourtant il ne m'a
pas draguer ça veut dire quoi je suis
pas assez bien pour toi connard
non c'est non
vincent leroy
merci à tous